Who doesn't love an Easter egg?
No, we're not talking about the egg-shaped
shells of chocolate goodness that have somehow
come to be a part of celebrating the resurrection
of Christ, we're talking about the unexpected
features and references in movies that eagle-eyed
viewers enjoy hunting for.Disney definitely
love Easter eggs.
Their movies are littered with countless examples
for audiences to spot - and, in this video,
we're going to run you through some of the
better examples in your favourite Disney offerings.
So sit back and relax, because you don't even
need to try when it comes to finding these
Easter eggs - we've got you covered - and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel,
so you can watch more video like this whenever
you log on.
Here are ten Easter eggs hidden in your favourite
Disney movies.
The Little Mermaid
Let's start with a real classic - in every
sense of the word.
1989's The Little Mermaid is a quintessential
Disney movie - and it features cameos from
some of Walt Disney's utmost classic Disney
mascots.When King Triton assembles a large
crowd of sea-dwelling beings in the movie's
opening scenes, none other than Mickey Mouse
himself, Donald Duck and Goofy can be seen
amongst the crowd.
But there's also a fun non-Disney cameo in
the same scene; Kermit the Frog can be seen
loitering a few rows behind the iconic Disney
trio.
The Incredibles
One of the best known and most regularly occurring
Disney Pixar Easter eggs is the mentioning
of "A113" - whether it be spoken or written
down somewhere within a movie.
It's the number of the classroom at the California
Institute of Arts where many of Pixar’s
earlier animators learned their trade.A prime
example is in 2004's The Incredibles (in which
it is actually mentioned on more than one
occasion).
Mirage says to Mr. Incredible "you'll be briefed
on your assignment in the conference room
at two.
D Wing, room A-113."
Toy Story 2
Another recurring Easter egg in Disney Pixar
movies is the inclusion of the Pixar corporate
mascot, Luxo Jr. - the little desk lamp that
appears on the production logo of every Pixar
movie.It has appeared in a number of movies
in various forms, but none were more imaginative
than its appearance in 1999's Toy Story 2.
It appears in a scene in which Buzz Lightyear
flies back down to Earth.
Luxo J. can be seen in the night sky as a
constellation in the vast sea of stars.
Toy Story 3
Ready for some trainspotting?
Good.In the opening sequence of 2010's Toy
Story 3, there's a runaway train that can
be seen bearing the number "95".
That number is a reference to the number on
Lightning McQueen in the Cars franchise which
is, in turn, a reference to 1995 - the year
that the first Toy Story movie was released.
Two Easter eggs for the price of one!
We're spoiling you here!
Cars
Having just mentioned the Cars franchise in
a Toy Story entry, it's now time to do the
reverse.
In 2006's Cars, there's a race called the
Piston Cup - and all of the cars taking part
in said race have tyres of a brand that is
a clear reference to a certain Toy Story character.Instead
of being "Goodyear" - like a lot of real world
tyres - these tyres are all of the fictional
brand "Lightyear".
This is, of course, taken from the name of
Buzz Lightyear - one of the heroes from the
aforementioned Toy Story movies.
The Hunchback of Notre Dame
Back to another Disney animated classic now
- it's 1996's The Hunchback of Notre Dame.
The majority of the movie takes place in a
single cathedral, which you'd imagine would
restrict the number of cameos Disney could
squeeze in - but that's not actually the case
at all!The opening scene alone sneaks in a
vendor selling Aladdin’s magic carpet, as
well as Belle from Beauty and the Beast out
for a walk.
And Pumbaa from The Lion King franchise even
makes an appearance in the movie - standing
guard as a stone gargoyle on a Paris building.
Finding Nemo
Most of Finding Nemo takes place under the
sea, but there are also some scenes in a dentist's
office where the titular fish finds himself
- and there are a couple of Easter eggs in
there.
For one, there's a young boy waiting in said
dentist's office, and he's reading a comic
with a picture of Mr. Incredible on it.Moreover,
as Nemo is looking around said dentist's office
for a way to escape the fish tank he's being
kept in, a Buzz Lightyear figure can be seen
lying on the floor in the corner.
Lilo & Stitch
Fa Mulan - star of Disney's 1998 movie Mulan
- disguised herself as a man in order to go
to war in place of her aging war veteran father.
As a result, she clearly made an impression
on the cast of characters in the world of
Lilo & Stitch!The 2002 Disney movie has a
couple of Easter eggs, both of which honour
the brave girl.
For one, a poster of Mulan hangs on Lilo’s
sister Nani’s wall.
Second, the family in the movie even walk
past a restaurant called “Mulan Wok”,
which appears to be quite clearly named after
her.
References to a Film That Never Was
This one's a little bit different.
Pixar are known for their foreshadowing Easter
eggs - by which we mean they like to include
Easter eggs that make reference to their movies
that haven't actually been released yet.
In this case, it's a movie that didn't actually
end up getting released at all.A shelved production
called Newt was referenced by way of a "Newt
Crossing" sign on Andy's door in Toy Story
3, and the witch in 2012's Brave can also
be seen holding a newt up when she's concocting
a spell.
Every Pixar Film
For our final entry, we get less specific,
as this Easter egg applies to every single
Disney Pixar film that was ever made.John
Ratzenberger - yeah, the guy from Cheers and
the Coors commercials - has voiced a character
in every Pixar film to date (and will no doubt
continue to do so going forward, because Pixar
consider him to be their good luck charm).
His characters have included the likes of
Toy Story's Hamm, A Bug's Life's P.T.
Flea, The Incredibles' Underminer and Mack
from Cars.
Thanks for watching our video about ten Easter
eggs hidden in your favourite Disney movies.
What other fun or interesting Easter eggs
can you think of from Disney offerings?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.